>>
Role models are definitely important for the
Middle East probably particularly with I think
women role models, successful , professional
women at a time when there are movements across
the region that believe the proper role for
woman is to be at home, in fact sometimes
only at home. I think it's important that
aspiring young woman who is seeking education
and career as well as family have professional
women to look up to and mentor them, encourage
them. I think also there needs to be people
who are willing to encourage critical thinking
within education, within business, within
government. The region is going to progress.
We have to have people in power to express
ideas that may not conform to the norm in
any of the institutions. But I think for the
progress of the entire region this is important.